[Music]  what is happening to our city hurry  I don't know feels like the end of the  world maybe it is Peter Parker how the  hell are you  the city is in danger he needs our help  all of our help  alright I'll call the play coach gang a  costume nutjobs is taking city apart  piece-by-piece  time I return the favor  this is opportunity knocking  you know the closer you get to them the  more you become a target right  the closer I get the better chance we  have to stop them  I've ordered silver sable and our team  to shoot you on sight  this city's had enough of your vigilante  you're officially an enemy of the people  [Music]  come on Peter  [Music]  how do I call you I mean who would you  have at a cell phone and your your pot  pockets or something  please